[MUSIC  PLAYING]
PAUL: So it's my turn to get
things off my chest I feel.
I recently built the
Chrome Dev Summit site.
JAKE: And a mighty fine job
I thought you did, as well.
PAUL: Thanks, pal.
JAKE: That's all right.
PAUL: But on my journey
through building that,
I discovered some gotchas.
First up-- position
fixed-- tell me
what you think position
fixed actually does?
JAKE: Takes an element
out of document flow,
and it positions it
relative to the viewport.
PAUL: The what?
JAKE: The viewport.
PAUL: The viewport.
The viewport.
JAKE: Right.
PAUL: Right.
JAKE: Was I right?
PAUL: When you apply a position
fixed to a child of something
that has a
transform-- so you got
another one with a transform--
and another element inside,
which is position fixed.
The position fixed
behavior changes.
The transformed element becomes
a new initial containing block.
JAKE: Whoa.
What?
PAUL: Yeah, it's like a new
viewport inside the viewport.
So the way I did
is it, because I
had these cards that
were transforming,
at the end of the transition,
I'd scale all the transforms,
so that I didn't see
weirdness on the content-- so
frustrating.
Gotcha number two-- pop state.
JAKE: Oh, yeah, I've
done pop state before.
PAUL: Yeah.
Did you know that it
restores scroll positions?
JAKE: No, actually I didn't.
PAUL: Right.
So this is bonkers to me.
You're doing something
with the history API,
you're pushing states on,
you're popping states off,
because you're handling
app state yourself.
But what the browsers
all do is they go,
I know what you want to do.
I know you want to restore
the scroll position
at the point at which
you did push state.
Which is, if you're doing
something async, right?
If you're doing something--
JAKE: Which is what I've
always done in the past.
PAUL: --yeah, then
all of a sudden,
your page would
just snap down to
its previous scroll position.
I thought I can fix this.
I'll work around
it-- gun fingers.
JAKE: [CLICKING SOUND] pow pow.
PAUL: What I'll do is I'll
have a single listener
for scroll position, and when it
switches, after the pop state,
it'll do one scroll.
I'll reverse it.
[? JAKE: P--Pull ?] me back.
PAUL: And they'll be like,
haha, never happened-- shazam.
No.
Because Chrome does
that-- it does the scroll
after the pop state.
Firefox does it before.
So you actually don't know
where you scrolled from.
You just know that you're
pretty certain you're not
in the scroll position
you were before.
Talking of scrolling--
last one-- body.
Did you know you can't stop
the body from scrolling?
JAKE: That's the name of
my next album, actually.
PAUL: Yeah, Jake.
That's great.
JAKE: Mousewheel events?
PAUL: You could, but that's
not going to work on mobile.
JAKE: On mobile-- which
you have touch events.
PAUL: No.
No.
JAKE: Because then
you're going to have
to re-implement
all of scrolling.
PAUL: All the fling
physics-y stuff.
JAKE: And if you do that,
you've lost performance,
lost everything, your life.
PAUL: Forget it.
Not doing that.
Don't like it.
Don't want it.
Because what happens, again,
these cards, they expand.
They've got scrollable
content inside.
When they reach the bottom
of their scrolling content,
the body goes, I will deal this.
I'll start scrolling now.
Well, there is an escape hatch,
an ability for a developer
to go, you know what?
I want to take control of this.
I know what's supposed
to happen here.
I will deal with it.
So extensible web says, nah.
JAKE: Nah.
PAUL: Right?
Exactly.
Good news, though.
In spec land, in
discussion world,
there is before scroll,
which is an event,
and its corresponding CSS
properties around what
scrolling should be blocked on.
But the default behavior
still remains as it is today.
It gives developers more options
to say, I know what I'm doing.
Please let me put the
car into my manual--
JAKE: Manual.
PAUL: --or stick shift, as it
were, and we'll go from there.
So from an extensible
web point of view, yay.
JAKE: Yay.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAKE: [LAUGHING]